[Applauso]
buonasera
si sente spesso parlare di paesaggio in
europa siamo abituati a pensarlo come
ciò che riusciamo a cogliere quello
sguardo
non possiamo pensare che sia solo questo
proviamo
proviamo con questa immagine
cosa significa per voi
bellissima per me ma oltre una
sensazione personale
cosa possiamo dire o capire di ciò che
vediamo
questo è un suono salino sotto il
livello del mare in contatto con una
falda salata
importa in particolari condizioni di
luce crea degli effetti ottici molto
suggestivi
questo è un suolo agricolo che si sta
stabilizzando
quindi non sarà anzi non è già più
coltivabile e tenderà alla
desertificazione
vorrei proporvi una diversa prospettiva
attraverso la mia esperienza personale
il mio lavoro di paesaggista
provo raccontandovi un aneddoto
anni fa in un viaggio in giappone
ho visitato il giardino zen più antico
del mondo irio angy
è conosciuto in particolare grazie al
suo giardino secco concepito come un
coan un indovinello paradossale che
aiutano la meditazione
presenta 15 pietre di grandezze
differente disposte in modo che da
qualsiasi punto si guardi non si possano
vedere tutte contemporaneamente
per poterle scorgere tutte è necessario
spostarsi e cambiare punto di
osservazione
tradizionalmente si ritiene che solo
raggiungendo l'illuminazione si possono
vedere tutti insieme
tornando al paesaggio è l'assenza del
tutto un insieme straordinariamente
complesso di più elementi collegati fra
loro
fiumi montagne
mare tracce di civiltà passate
come ci insegna il giardino zen per
poter scorgere la sua essenza
incredibilmente complessa e ricca di
significati e fondamentale cambiare
sguardo prospettiva punto di vista
i paesaggi buttano nel corso del tempo
ma questi cambiamenti non sono sempre
percepibili a prima vista
pensiamo ad esempio al territorio della
pianura padana
sottratti alle acque in un lungo e
susseguirsi di opere di bonifica
dove c'era il mare ora ci sono città
campagne
le tracce dell'antico porto romano di
classe evidenziano chiaramente l'antica
linea di costa dove ora si fa
agricoltura
mi sono spesso chiesta se esista una
chiave di lettura che ci aiuti a leggere
questo dinamismo ed è ciò di cui vorrei
parlarvi oggi
un elemento che sfugge a un occhio
inesperto è il suolo come materia da cui
dipende l'evoluzione dei paesaggi sia
essa naturale o antropica
mi interessano gli aspetti non sempre
percepibili da noi umani ma fondamentali
per altre specie viventi e per il nostro
stesso benessere
in questo periodo storico più di altri
ci chiediamo come trasformare e adattare
i territori per fronteggiare sfide
globali come i cambiamenti climatici
e come evolveranno i paesaggi dipende
dalle strade che intendiamo percorrere
in questo la gestione dei suoli sarà la
nostra bussola poiché il suolo è il
punto di collegamento centrale fra i
problemi ambientali globali come i
cambiamenti climatici la gestione delle
risorse idriche e la perdita di
biodiversità
ma cos'è realmente il suolo
per solo si intende lo strato superiore
della crosta terrestre
formate da minerali gas acqua
microrganismi che lo abitano e
favoriscono i processi di decomposizione
di piante animali
formando la materia organica
è la pelle viva del pianeta terra
svolge diverse funzioni alcune chimico
fisica come il ciclo naturale dell'acqua
dell'aria e delle sostanze organiche e
minerali
è un'importante trappola per il carbonio
quindi fondamentale nella regolazione
dell'effetto serra
per l'ecologia è considerato l'unità
centrale di trasformazione dell'ambiente
terrestre
altre funzioni sono invece i materiali
in quanto componente della memoria
storica culturale e biologica luogo
sacro per determinate religioni e
oggetto di ricerca
tutto ha origine dal suolo
per migliaia di anni tantissime culture
hanno espresso questo riconoscimento
attraverso la religione l'arte o la
scrittura
e secondo il libro della genesi dio
formo l'uomo dalla polvere soffione le
sue narici soffre della vita e l'uomo
divenne anima vivente
dio ha fatto un uomo adamo dalla polvere
e così creato gli esseri umani
secondo diverse interpretazioni
il nome di adamo è connesso all'ebraico
adam a terra suolo e la parola omo che
significa umano viene da humus cioè
terreno fertile
nel mondo virtuale di oggi si è perso il
contatto con il suolo
ma il nostro benessere e sopravvivenza
dipendono dalla sua salute
dalla sua capacità di funzionare come un
sistema vivente
non solo che non è in salute è degradato
e fattori di degrado sono molteplici
come l'inquinamento
l'erosione l'impermeabilizzazione la
presenza massiccia di pesticidi e
nutrienti
il suolo
è un ecosistema su palazzo scala
microscopica un habitat per
microrganismi batteri vermi insetti che
favoriscono la sua rigenerazione e
formazione
la presenza di materia organica è
fondamentale per la sua salute è
l'elisir di lunga vita per le piante ne
determina la fertilità ne mantiene la
struttura e accelera i processi di
decomposizione delle sostanze inquinanti
struttura del sole mineralogia sono
proprietà intrinseche che cambiano molto
lentamente nel tempo mentre la materia
organica risponde rapidamente i
cambiamenti indotti dall'uomo
per esempio l'utilizzo massiccio di
diserbanti non cambia la struttura di un
terreno ma incide profondamente nella
vita che lo abita
negli ultimi 50 anni abbiamo trasformati
suoli terrestri più intensamente
rapidamente che in qualsiasi altro
periodo della storia umana con
l'obiettivo di soddisfare la domanda in
rapida crescita di cibo acqua dolce
materie prime e combustibili
ciò ha causato uno stato di salute
precario per i suoli con conseguenze
sugli ecosistemi del pianeta terra
le ricadute in termini economici sono
altissime
in europa i costi associati con il
degrado dei suoli sono di 50 miliardi di
euro all'anno
dunque per gestire suono in maniera
sostenibile
serve spazio per la vita
come si può fare quindi a gestire il
suolo in maniera sostenibile mantenere
la vita al suo interno e garantire il
nostro benessere
queste sono domande importanti da porci
come progettisti e le gestione le forme
di gestione sostenibile del territorio
considerano l'uso la trasformazione del
suolo insieme alle vocazioni naturali di
un luogo
proviamo a immaginarsi le conseguenze di
due atteggiamenti radicalmente opposti
veli mostri estremizzati in queste due
immagini
possiamo continuare a utilizzare il
territorio e con infrastrutture che lo
cristallizzano strusi consumo tale
operazione limita ai processi di
rigenerazione del suolo la dinamicità
ambientale e mette in crisi le risorse a
nostra disposizione
oppure potremmo lasciare che la natura
si riprende lentamente i suoi spazi
accettando di confinare che le nostre di
confinare le nostre esigenze che
attualmente si percuotono sulla
conservazione della natura e sulla
salute stessa del sole
beh la risposta non può essere univoca a
domande così complesse non corrispondono
risposte banali ma esistono soluzioni in
grado di far convivere le esigenze
antropiche ed economiche quelle
dinamiche naturali ed ecologiche
progettare il suolo è un'operazione
complessa che coinvolge tantissime
discipline
per fare questo tranne in prestito gli
occhi di altri
infatti io sono un architetto e nel mio
lavoro mi confronto è costantemente con
geologi agronomi biologi chimici che mi
aiutano decifrare il linguaggio della
natura ea tradurlo in scelte progettuali
progettare il paesaggio è un'azione
corale un ascolto reciproco di voci che
sconfina in un linguaggio comune in cui
gli aspetti tecnici si nutrano delle
nostre aspirazioni e del nostro vissuto
personale
questo approccio si deve riflettere su
più dimensioni dal territorio al micro
habitat suolo
come possiamo farlo
i boschi le zone umide le torbiere sono
preziosissime riserve di materia
organica
grazie alla presenza di aqmi dita e
fondamentale ripristinarle preservarle
anche in zone antropizzate
vanno individuati dei luoghi adatti come
quelli che vi sto mostrando
per riattivare processi di recupero
della biodiversità sia in superficie che
nel terreno
questi arrivano rimodellate per poter
accogliere la presenza di elementi
naturali acqua vegetazione autoctona
la vegetazione depura l'acqua ne
favorisce l'infiltrazione in falda e si
creano le condizioni per il
ripopolamento di particolari specie
ripristinando queste dinamiche si può in
tribuna preservare la salute del suolo
fondamentale per la sostenibilità
alimentare
come vedremo nel video anche solo con i
piccoli interventi che a volte possono
sembrare insignificanti o marginali
possiamo contribuire attivare questi
meccanismi
un'accorta modellazione del terreno per
esempio può ricreare una piccola zona
umida
spesso i luoghi in cui non riconosciamo
il nostro habitat ci appaiono ostili o
non utile ai nostri fini in realtà
collaborano a mantenere il suolo in
salute un alto livello di biodiversità
ambientale
ea lasciare lo spazio per quella vita
fondamentale per il nostro benessere
solo con una corretta programmazione dei
processi antropici sulle dinamiche
ambientali e viceversa si possono
controllare gli effetti spesso negativi
degli eventi naturali sul territorio e
dell'uomo sull'ambiente
dobbiamo essere noi il motore di un
rinnovato rapporto con la natura
il paesaggio non va inteso come una
scena passiva ma come un sistema attivo
e funzionale connesso all'habitat umano
e si misura con la gestione dei suoli
vorrei salutarvi con una frase di claude
lévi strauss a me cara che racchiude il
senso di ciò che vi ho appena raccontato
l'uomo deve rendersi conto che occupa
nel creato uno spazio infinitamente
piccolo e che nessuna delle sue
invenzioni estetiche può competere con
un minerale un insetto o un fiore un
uccello uno scarabeo o una farfalla
meritano la stessa fervida attenzione di
un quadro di tiziano del tintoretto
ma noi abbiamo dimenticato come guardare
[Applauso]